[Triumphant music]
- [Grunting]
I'm back...on...top!
[Sun shuriken whirring]
[Splashing, sizzling]
- OK, you've had your shot. It's my time now.
- Luka?! If anyone's taking the
MVP idol from Jokic,
it's the winner of last year's one seed.
[Chiming]
- And how'd that work out for you? Huh?
[Fire igniting and water swirling]
[Laughing]
[Thundering]
- Wow!
The wonders of this strange land
never cease to amaze!
[Crashing]
You guys coming?
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
[Steady footsteps]
[Giannis:] Ah, man. Jokic does everything for
1.6-Kilometer-High City.
- This is why an elite fighter like you—
or me—must stop him from getting a third idol.
- Oh. So you're on Giannis ' level now?
- [Luka]: Hahaha. OK.
[Whooshing]
- This is the closest I've been to a real trophy.
- Don’t! Jokic’s MVPs are rigged!
[Earth rumbling]
- [Luka and Devin]: Ahh!
- [Giannis]: Whee!
Oh. Another Giannis wall.
[Dribbling]
[Fire igniting]
- Point God, show me the way.
[Quickening footfalls]
[Gasp] Chris?
[Footfalls fading]
[Sigh] Deandre?
[Water dripping]
- Ah, well. I am used to being alone.
- [Menacing laughing]
- He's...here.
[Striking dynamite fuse]
- Hello.
- [Screaming]
- Here we go.
[Hook whirring]
[Steady footsteps]
- Stop hiding the MVP away in the mountains!
It belongs in a bigger market!
- Are we really doubling in open combat?
- Almost ready.
[Hook still whirring]
- I have many weapons in my arsenal.
[Dynamite sizzling and exploding]
[Warping]
- Ow! In the back? Who does that?
[Brand sizzling]
- Wet.
[Hammer thudding]
[To himself] He can sense where I am without looking.
I don't know if I can beat him without help.
[Earth bursting]
- [Powerful echoing] I am here for the idol.
Aye, man. This place is very nice!
[Water swirling]
- Ahhh!
- I will not be cooled off!
[Hammer thuds]
[Bursting]
- Goodbye!
- You had one job, Joker.
The Association's displeased.
[Nuggets whooshing]
[Chuckling] You know I live online.
Channel your rage at stopping these targets.
[Suspenseful music]
- Hmm.
[Joyful, playful music]